hey guys first of all thank you for
clicking you're about to watch a new
video or another video on YouTube and
before you do - one two nine three one
five seven three one what I'm doing in
my text community is bonkers it's
instant it's access it's exclusive and
now enjoy this YouTube video to me if
you're selling to fifteen to twenty
five-year-olds anything and you don't
have an uncomfortable strategy
uncomfortable as a slang term for all in
creating everyday at scale on tick-tock
you're missing one of the great kind of
moments and the [ __ ] can go away you got
your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
what was the biggest aha you were at
Facebook for a decade what when you you
know obviously besides seeing that whole
thing happen and obviously I'm assuming
but correct me if I'm wrong you're like
wait a minute this platform has a real
chance of potentially being the next one
let me be a smart executive obviously
there's some opportunity and being
early-ish what was the AHA of the
platform that was different than what
you've seen before that really kind of
gave you the strategic or courage to
make that kind of career move I'll give
you to like yeah Facebook is where
members are yeah and you kind of look
down this is an amazing on for about the
passion was I was working out of
discussion saying that's where were you
at the time at the time I was a dog
understanding Yahoo okay yeah
the aha moment with tick tock was when I
met Amy who's the founder to see yeah
and it was very very they're very
different two of them right but they're
both engineers they're both super
passionate they're amazing founders and
entrepreneurs and at the end of the day
they both want to make the world a
better place right and when you see that
combined with some of the metrics and we
saw the metrics earlier on the Facebook
sighs well the metrics and tick-tock
were astounded like I know they're no
surprises people in this room the reason
folks are sitting here is because of the
numbers right yeah and the reason
Thompson here was killed numbers and the
reason that you talk so passionately
about platforms to the numbers so and
just them add my two cents
just like I also recognize a lot of
people in this room might have a side
hustle and are trying to get something
started or have a friend who does or has
some other things that she or he wants
to talk about in the world that other
platforms can't I didn't the thing that
tik-tok has and I mentioned it earlier
today LinkedIn ironically is going
through the same thing there's always
this time when these platforms are so
big that there is so much so big with
attention that there's not enough
content to fill it to ultimately not
create a scenario where you can get an
incredible amount of awareness and reach
when you have no audience I think the
thing that's been most interesting to me
over the last two months and I don't
think I've seen this
a long long time where the nature of
tick-tocks algorithm and just how much
consumption is happening there and I've
been talking about it quite a bit over
the last hundred days I've been
bombarded with emails and DMS from
people who desperately been trying to
create on YouTube and Instagram for the
last three years eight hours a day and
within six days nineteen days have built
such bigger audiences and engagement not
just numbers of followers on tick-tock
and that's reminiscent to the people I
saw on Twitter in that first 2006 to
2008 world you were able to get so many
more followers because the nature was
everybody followed everybody because it
was such a small community and you were
able to get a lot of awareness and
before we do anything else I think we
all chase awareness the industry has
been overpricing potential reach with
GRPs and impressions and programmatic
and here's a platform though I still
believe skews to a certain demo that may
not match everybody potentially has its
way to match everybody but has in
essence free awareness that is very
difficult to achieve in other places and
I think that in itself is important yeah
I think us question all around there
kind of brands and how they think about
it and you know for me the you know I've
been with the company for six months by
no means do I have all the answers not
argue we don't have a lot of the answers
and one of the things that I'm really
trying to emphasize teams come around
the world is if you we need help like
we're trying to learn as we go but it is
different the environments the brands
have to think differently about their
presence in the platform and we have
some amazing brands are doing some
really cool work and they're the kind of
early adopters it's the nineties
Burberry's Samsung's doing some amazing
things and I've to talk about lots of
different executions and and how they
view it and one thing in common that
buddy has is kind of a willingness to
try first and foremost you know they
think a little bit differently so it's
not about how do we just take content
that I'm running on insta or Facebook or
snap or yeah ESPN or wherever might be
running or YouTube and trying to cut it
and paste it and stick it on to
tick-tock there is a little bit of a
different nuance to it and the greatest
success problems were having is when
they are engaging with the audience
I assume you would believe that to be
true for every platform that the context
of the creative is one of the big
conversations our industry is not having
enough up
absolutely absolutely on this platform
audiences are so engaged like it's yummy
when with people in great examples you
know what might be the MAC Cosmetics
execution at Fashion Week right they
retain three influencers enable and
patents in photos so they brought them
to the shows of them they did as soon as
a campaign around your beauty right so
it's all about you and your beauty and
transformation of beauty and they ended
up with these three influences afraid to
amazing content you put it in that
context ripping it up on the platform
then they had a 250,000 other people
crazy content with the hashtag and then
different like I think the number was
closer to billion video views right all
from a relatively small investment in
time and energy how are you guys they
actually don't even know this because
I'm just in full content and read
comments how are you guys
counting video views is that three
seconds like what is your metric yep
Danica's full video views right for
advertising you're working with both IES
and others around you go to standard or
some understand I will say it's nice
like so we only launched on boat is
integrations maybe six eight weeks ago
which might sound crazy for a cognitive
we kind of appear to be this massive
company even I would argue that in many
parts of the world we still behave it's
intentional like Astana we're still
building the foundation again something
I don't know and I have no clue if you
guys are publicly saying this I what
always gets my attention is when apps
sheet to the top of the download list
I'm just fascinated by people in
marketing who don't download every one
of those apps and plays so I know it
takes a lot to get there and stay there
as long as tick tock has been there but
when's the last time tic toc announced
how many users are on the platform or or
how many users are on the platform
we're pretty cool brands we don't do it
publicly okay that's why I hedged I have
no idea but it's more than how global is
it given it's a Chinese base camp like
how like where where it
I always remember you know I was just in
Brazil which is a lot of fun for the
first time for me and which is unusual
for me I travel so much and it was so
fun to talk about Orkut because back in
2000 you know when when I was doing this
in oh seven oh eight it was so
fascinating to see Orkut be the dominant
social you know this is this was the
toughest battle for Facebook back in a
day i remember you know so are there any
pockets that tic toc has completely
exploded in you know I'm always
fascinated by the global thing like
Twitter like it's stunningly a
non-player in Germany for example like
most fascinated by the global dynamics
has there been a market where tic toc
has completely exploded recently or
anything anything interesting to share
up for context amia
india's been exceptional yeah notice
like and you know that culturally
culturally just resonates and so there's
been a lot of growth in the indie market
but other parts of asia as well
tick tock doesn't exist in china and say
it's autonomous from the the the Chinese
on the business run it outside of
outside of the Chinese market
they brought it very locally said this
in the US is run by teams in the US
business run your team is run by teams
in Europe so but is it is pretty it's
pretty it's pretty around the world it's
pretty it's pretty common I mean I think
the big thing is it's what's interesting
is people are so what's the difference
between you and then Facebook or
Instagram or Twitter or snapping em up
in and I would say that you know some of
those platforms are very amount of
social plot there's social networks
right and that's the world they live in
and and we do get bucked in social
I would argue not a social network right
it's because at the end of the day my
content and necessarily I don't care
about friends and family matter fact I'm
not connected to any friends family or
tick tock but as any social network
playing that game yeah I mean the
evolutional you know people creating
Finster's and like secondary things but
the reality is all of this has opened
you know it's really fascinating to
watch it all happen right I mean the
notion of a place for friends and family
has for a far majority of consumers is
now their text messaging or their what's
it like you know it's it's I mean tick
tock in its execution as a social
network has massive similarities to you
know an Instagram for example I guess I
guess I'm probably a little bit skewed
on to describe Facebook because that's
right the wrong sure and be part of the
family you're you're deeply involved in
shortened so in my experience on those
platforms is very much friends and
family and then obviously brands whereas
my experience on tick tock is very much
wrong in contact what's interesting
about that though is when you look at a
14 or 15 year old you know a lot of them
that is their friend Network it you know
it is being controlled by a parent to
allow just their friends and therefore
camp friends or things that make sure
it's almost like where your starting
point is becomes your friend Network
then it evolves and then it's
interesting to watch people maintain a
place for their friends and it's just
the evolution of when you get into a
platform Gen Z's definitely coming up on
tick-tock who's there platform right so
I was I was having dinner with my wife
younger kids maybe two weeks ago there
were a couple probably seniors in high
school you have girls over the corner
doing some like tick-tock right and sure
enough they were putting their kid Tech
Talks for their friends right course I
never around Vail having a hike there
was a family like a family with maybe 10
12 13 year-old kids mom dad and they
were doing the same thing on the trail
and going up the map there was kind of
halfway into the mountain created tick
tock video and my wife was kind of blown
away by this
and then took cancer here people do this
number go to some different world she
she grew up in the Facebook family as
well and uh and then funny enough to
give two weeks eighty two weeks ago Tom
Brady joins tick-tock now all sudden she
downloading tick tock she's like I love
tick tock I'm not engaging [ __ ] hate
that dude yeah like hate like not even
like not even like plight claps that we
were doing that like [ __ ] hate you
bro you can ask the next question I'm
not even excited I'm just super on tilt
man my football like life is the worst I
would rip my [ __ ] arms off to be an
Eagles fan
you guys want a [ __ ] Super Bowl two
minutes ago with the [ __ ] having them
into one eye well I'm gonna [ __ ] what
else and the one thing they say is when
they watch on tick-tock it just goes
fast I think the content for whatever
screen by the social graph whatever you
want to call it right then when they put
it pops when it pops it just goes really
there's so much attention on your
platform right now I mean it's not super
complicated it went really fast on vine
- it went really fast on Instagram when
Instagram didn't have enough creators
making for it this is one big game of
supply and demand of content and the
attention on the other side yeah and
it's gonna go really fast until the
attention doesn't match the amount of
output it's just the same old game this
is this is one game played over and over
again and by the way and went back to
television but in modern times this is
email marketing yah
email open rates for very developed
email newsletters in the 1996 to 1999
range had scary numbers like 80% open
rates
90% open rates because nobody was
emailing
you know and we you know how many people
here had email in 1997 just raise your
hands raise them high cuz I want the
kids to see this
remember how we read every [ __ ] email
back then and so there's this attention
graph that plays out and and I mean you
intimately know this this was what I was
yelling about in two thousand nine ten
eleven about Facebook I'm like these
pages organic reach is remarkable and
I'm like and it will go away and it was
and it was not because I knew anything
other than it always goes away it tick
tock inevitably unless it's able to suck
out all the collective attention of the
world at all times eventually there's a
crescendo there's a tipping point where
there's more content being produced plus
you'll eventually I think maybe not
create a product where people can start
showing up in the feed or other places
it's just it's a land grab it's like
buying up beachfront property in Malibu
somebody did that and eventually got
more expensive and so yeah I mean I
speak to all the creators top down a lot
and I'm spending a ton of time talking
them over the last 150 days and you're
absolutely right and and we're and we're
I'm really passionate is being a creator
now is like everybody's dream at a youth
level and then more importantly for a
lot of people here storytelling and
having it seen is very important and I
think it's one thing for a creator
that's already one on YouTube or
Instagram or somewhere else when they
come over what's been so fun for me is
seeing these people who desperately
desperately have tried for the last
three years and seeing how quick the
results are and look you know flag in
the ground because I try to be
historically correct you know I have no
equity or involvement with tik-tok I
give a [ __ ] if it disappears tomorrow I
fair enough for you know I respect
respect I'm sure that tenure run in
Facebook wasn't the worst Blake but
nonetheless
nonetheless I think for me it's like hey
how many more times that's this industry
bad week need to see this show to
understand what the game is the game is
very simple things emerge that have
uncomfortable amounts of attention in
comparison to how much output creatively
is there and those are incredible times
to story tell and learn and people
waiting for it to be real or some
reporting mechanism to you know the end
of the rub and you know this is your
guy's world the rub of waiting for
reporting to justify your spend on it is
the rub it's no different than podcast
pre-roll right now I mean there's no
confusion that there's an enormous
amount of people listening to podcasts
but watching people not buy ads because
the reporting isn't in place yet is why
people don't do it and that's why
entrepreneurs and startups always grow
because big companies trade on fake
metrics and small companies trade on
truth yeah I mean it's it's it's it's
it's it's historically correct you know
all that tick-tock for me being the
first brand to go heavy into tick-tock
that is targeting that demo because I
still don't fully know where the demos
but let's let's just say skews younger
for now it's no different than Procter &
Gamble being the biggest spender on
television in the 50s and 60s because
that was the arbitrage or wish the
shopping app you probably knew this I
mean this is what Facebook executives
joke about all the time there's all
these companies and LLC's that nobody's
ever heard of spending uncomfortable
amounts of money and coke and BMW are
spending a third of that and everyone's
confused what's going on to me if you're
selling to 15 to 25 year olds anything
and you don't have an uncomfortable
strategy uncomfortable as a slang term
for all in creating every day at scale
on tick-tock you're missing one of the
great kind of moments and the [ __ ] can
go away you know and and they come and
still goes with you one of things that
I'm always fascinated by is people like
well Gary what if it goes away in three
years I'm like you take the brand equity
with you there was a lot of people who
built a lot of brand equity on vine and
when they started creating on snap or
Instagram
the
it's a percentage of it went I don't
know why everybody's so literal you're
so happy to mark it on Super Bowl or on
television or an outdoor that goes away
- but there's something ideological in
the system that has this sad feeling
that it might turn into my space you
know my preference is that they all die
because that means the attentions moving
and it will always benefit the quickest
and the people that are most willing to
play that game which is my most
comfortable game you know I love having
debates with people about the past the
past is always people's vulnerability to
the current and definitely to the future
so I think that listen I'm a big fan of
everything you said right I love this
space and the reason my doing the
company turns out to an inflection point
where you know it's having to learn it's
having to grow up a little bit to having
to think differently you know tapping to
create some standards does have to have
some measure ability Caprice people come
100 percent ins not only being seen but
it's having an impact on awareness
consideration and real quick on that I
apologize like that's all true and all
please hear that has nothing to do with
what the consumer is actually doing
that's the rub of course that's gonna
happen that's why you go there and that
will play out over time but every second
you wait for that to happen the
underpriced attention becomes more
expensive inflection up until now but so
probably a month ago I think a lot of
that was true they were very there there
were good brands who come on the
platform there were dozens and dozens
and dozens in the last month for
whatever reason there's been a real
reflection well everybody's back from
the summer everything they could be
because I'm such a great job oh god
that's where you were going through I
think it's [ __ ] audio but it could be
when you start to talk a lot about I
don't know about that but there is a lot
more activity now I mean and then and
some of the more mid what I would call
mainstream and really your powerful
brands or get on the platform and
experiment yeah right because it is
about experimenting it's not you know
the point you made earlier is if we can
easily launch a platform and so let's
just take all this take fifteen seven
from wherever else inspecting our feed
right and build a currency around it and
skilled business we could do that all
day long but when I talk to your leading
brands like you try to say that we want
to be different we want brands to be
really this kind of this this
first-class citizen in the graph so that
when people see the content they
actually engage with it right then
engage with it and they become connected
where your rub is as a platform has been
historic which is getting brands to be
contextual creatively is the rub it is
hard because they are partnered with
people often that don't contextualize
creative or they don't see it real quick
I apologize because I don't know if
we're supposed to do this we're gonna
take some questions right yeah is that
what you said okay do you guys know
about this the slide oh stuff like okay
cool sorry yeah Walmart's got a great
activation you know to see is saving
shuffle it's in the stores its kind of
gaijin it's beginning Walmart which is
kind of one of the biggest brands
certainly in the u.s. you know engaging
with that audience is a big deal right
it's kind of one of those seminal
moments you start seeing those kind of
brands and we're seeing that with with a
variety of HP didn't do amazing we saw
Chipotle some some great thing yes lots
of great there's lots of great work I'm
gonna jump in on number four cuz I'm
excited about it I don't know if they're
showing it up there but the question is
how can tik-tok ensure they will not
have the same destiny as vine I touched
on this earlier you know for them at
least what I've seen historically for
the last 10 years they're gonna have to
continue to innovate the product right I
think if you look at vine it got stuck
it just stopped innovating features
obviously got bought by Twitter and so
it had those dynamics platforms they've
been able to continue to innovate with
trends I mean look at Facebook now
they're pushing groups because that's
innovating what they're like what's the
behavior on that platform I think one
more time though because I think this is
the biggest value out I can bring here
we have to start looking at these
platforms like shows not like channels
like again when it's relevant you mark
it on it when could shell is that its
hottest you activate there when you know
when nobody
watches the Super Bowl in 30 years if
that's the case I have a funny feeling
nobody's gonna buy Super Bowl ads it's
not complicated what I tend to do is
spend hundreds of hours consuming
content but more importantly comments I
spend almost like it when I think about
the last the hundred hours plus that
I've spent in the last couple months on
tick tock 90% of it has been reading
comments of the piece of content so I go
into you know for you or where it's
Explorer or things that are popping or
get into a hashtag portal or you know
see something popping and of course I'll
look at the singular piece of content
and that takes two seconds on the
platform or six or what-have-you
it's actually spending next 15 minutes
reading how people react to it so you
know for me it's seeing new acronyms
slang term it's been super interesting
to your point over the last 45 days I
always loved and I loved it on snap and
I loved it on vine when people that
aren't 15 start coming onto the platform
like nothing makes me laugh more than
like seeing some to go viral and just
reading comments and you can look at the
profile and see it's like a 30 40 50 60
70 year-old and 94% of the comments or
what the [ __ ] is this you know you know
which is like the best right like you
just learn and so I'm looking up that
didn't happen during Tom Brady know I
the number one thing I look for I think
will resonate with this audience is I'm
spending all my time looking for are
there nuances that make me believe that
this is going to age up and stick around
but that doesn't stop me from making at
scale and extracting awareness at the
time and you know no different than MTV
and then what that evolves into if you
have ambition to be successful at your
craft understanding what's going on here
now is going to play dividends for the
rest of your career I think the reason
snap and vine and insert of stories and
tick tock came so natural to me is
because social cam was an app that used
the algorithm of remember that do you
remember that pop I don't know how many
of you guys remember Socialcam but for
like 48
gets it popped and it was the same time
that you know Photo Booth was popping
you know and and so like the idea of
storytelling that way you know you could
see so many of the nuances of the
content today on tick-tock that are
grounded in the DNA of Socialcam and
vine and musically and that's important
because then you start understanding how
to story tell because being a creator as
a creative director for a brand I think
we all know this like having the tough
conversations as they evolve with the
biggest brands in the world to justify
why to be on this it has to go much
deeper than you know test and learn is
always right and you're seeing that now
but at some point this conversations
gonna evolve into is this doing anything
for my business and the only way to
actually make that happen is to be a
relevant storyteller within the context
of the four walls that were in and that
takes strategy let alone contextual
output that leads into a good question
which is out and how do you see a
creator for tik-tok evolving in the
context of Facebook Instagram stories
look I think from my perspective the
industry the reason I fell in love with
the feed right the idea of those ads was
there was less friction in that at the
time than there was in a pop up on a
website in a pre-roll before you saw
what you wanted to see and the native
integration of that was far greater than
anything I had seen which is why I came
natural to me because I think friction
to the consumer is the devil and so I
was pot committed and it had its run and
now I think we can all recognize that
we've been conditioned to expect ads in
a feed which means inevitably it will
decline in its relevance with human
conditioning I don't know what tick
tocks thinking I think you've alluded to
it twice and I think it will always be
an interesting thing of like how do we
get brands to actually be great at just
creative on the platform but for me it's
always the least friction within the
four walls of where you're consuming to
actually get the ad across integral
the content is always the best way to do
it especially if you can do it but if
you can't and you have empathy for the
fact that tic TOCs building a business
and will create ad products it'll be
interesting to see where it goes you
know it's funny you guys started doing
the ad that like is just there for
everybody when you open that has such
great scale and it reminded me of
anything topic on Twitter I don't know
if you guys remember - a trending topic
ad on Twitter when it was still a
desktop app and there wasn't like
heavily mobile and I would show you
trending and you could have the number
one you can have the ad above the number
one trending out and I remember we did
some stuff for GE and Green Mountain
Coffee that was uncomfortably successful
because of just the sheer awareness just
good old-fashioned actual consumption
and awareness which is you know the
counter to contextual at scale so it's
interesting to see you guys have already
gone there and I think you'll be I don't
know where you guys plan on going but
the least amount of friction will result
in the best results the ones I think
your live so there's there's cool
products for the audience to this
because you can see with the hashtag
challenge which is basically ingredients
like the mean culture or the top view
which is kind of what Walmart in today
which is coming up mass scale I just
truly believe if people would pull me
aside and say where do you want the
world to go I really want this to be
heavily driven around native feeling
that I want Brandon to feel like they
belong in the feet I don't want to be
interrupted by greatness my friend Mark
Garcia but basically to say your
advertising was it's all about there to
burning people away from the content to
talk to your brand right and I really
want brands because the success they're
happy when they engage audiences it's
it's cheap altair with a beep yeah MAC
Cosmetics or whatever with Ralph Lauren
did with the USO of it with a hashtag I
mean like this the numbers are
staggering
that's because the sheer scale because
they're actually engaging these folks
and the creatives being created by the
by the audience let me slip slip this in
because I think it'll help the audience
I'm generally curious as well once best
use thought beyond Gen Z and then the
other and I think it just went away
which is - it said you're saying that we
should get them ticked I remember
because I read it you're saying that we
should be on tick-tock right now to grab
this underpriced the tension but is it
relevant for things outside of Gen Z in
its most simple point are you confident
and comfortable at this point telling
brands that are marketing to people that
are twenty five to forty five let's just
start with that wide massive demo that
there's enough user attention on a
platform there justifies the investment
to put into the platform absolutely I
mean it's a fully I mean a year and a
half ago I might not be able to make
that comment is purely musically
technologies fundamentally shifted from
a demographic and from a Content
diversity forget about the content that
versity which I think you guys to your
point have done an extremely good job to
make sure it's not lip-syncing like how
are you like this is actually a very
selfish question because I'm getting hit
up by my brands I'm I'm not on common
sense paying attention with no data
behind
I'm not comfortable saying hey you're
targeting thirty to thirty eight year
olds and and we should really be
spending real time and money on this
platform to extract attention to create
consideration are you guys sharing with
brands numbers they're brought them is
not coming seventeen year olds because
you're not capturing before you're using
third-party data overlay on that because
you're not asking for net info right we
are using our own date on that because
it's part of this part of the
registration process you don't recall it
this one because you put in your data
okay well with seven seconds left I just
have to say [ __ ] Tom Brady awesome you
guys got thank you thank you guys take
care